hi good evening everyone can you see me
well
comment while we start our live stream
see good
glances people are active good to see
all right
greening everyone and i see participants
coming in so let's give them some
time like a minute
sorry for being four minutes late but
just one more minute and we're gonna get
started
and the livestream is active
welcome everyone again
right let's get started
okay good evening and good morning to
everyone who's uh joined from different
parts of the world
uh it gives me immense pleasure in
welcoming you your family your friends
present here for the second online
convocation summary for the year 2022 or
should buy simply learn in association
with caltech ctme
i'm naveen srinivasan senior program
manager at simply learn responsible for
learner success for ctme and other
technology programs at simply
first and foremost i would like to say a
big congratulations to all the graduates
who have achieved something which many
claim to be impossible i can understand
there is an ad of excitement amongst
everyone
this air of excitement is all about you
where your family your friends the
faculty the management at caltech simply
learn and every single person present
here today is very proud of
this is when i remember my convocation
uh at my preschool where i was nervous i
was excited about the future and at the
same time i had a huge sense of relief
uh that all the hard work and struggle
was done and now i take a back seat and
just relax and enjoy the moment i'm
pretty sure many of you here would
resonate to my thoughts today is it
so uh let's take a step back and remind
ourselves about uh the journey we have
been through
uh i believe the most difficult part for
any learner must have to be sit through
eight hours every weekend week week week
after week for like eight to six months
eight to twelve months and uh this is no
joke right and this can only be achieved
with sheer determination and support
from your friends and family that said i
would like to also thank them and for
their continued support and making them
part of your success story
the road to success comes with hundreds
of hours of learning through lpc classes
uh the online self learning videos and
doing 20 plus assessments and not to
forget the quizzes and then finally
implementing all your knowledge and uh
completing the capstone project
right that's when you go and unlock your
certificate and it honestly requires a
lot of commitment and passion to achieve
this and i would like to take this
moment to applaud and appreciate each
one of you fire effort you guys are
amazing thank you so much
so next um i will quickly do a round of
introduction of our chief guest today uh
it gives me immense pleasure in
introducing our sponsor for tonight uh
our chief product officer anand varadin
anand holds a masters in computer
science and is an mba from the
university of texas at austin uh he's
immensely passionate about customer
success and believes that product has a
strong role to play in engaging with
customers at various levels
during his time as a product leader he
has won multiple innovation awards and
truly believes in delivering world-class
products by bettering them to test
anand is extremely passionate about this
program and he has been a key factor to
the success of this program it's a
success for the program at simply
next we have uh dr rick hefner it gives
me immense pleasure to introduce uh the
first guest of honor today dr rick
heffner he's the program director at uh
california institute of technology he's
an extremely humble person to work with
and his achievements speak volume over
what an academician is
he's an alumni of purdue university and
has completed his phd in mechanical
engineering from ucla
dr hefner is extremely knowledgeable
across a
broad varieties of discipline related to
software and system engineering and also
process improvements
his insight and guidance has been
immensely valuable to the success of
this program
uh thank you dr hefner for being uh here
today and then uh next i'm delighted to
introduce our second guest of honor for
today mike ash
he is the program director at caltech
ctme uh mike is extremely passionate
about new age technologies and how how
the impact of it would make the society
and the world building a better place
he's at harvard business school alumni
and he has also been associated with
many fortune 100 companies in
formulating competitive strategies uh
guiding them to industry ships in terms
of digitization globalization and
consumer preference anand it's all yours
but i think this is a moment where folks
are really excited to hear from rick i
would rather that rick starts our
proceedings today so rick i'll give you
the stage and i will speak after you and
add some thoughts to what you would like
to say over to you
you know that's very kind of you um so
first of all
on behalf of caltech let me welcome
everybody here to the caltech family um
caltech is a very very special place
we
have the
responsibility of marshaling some of the
world's greatest minds to solve some of
the world's greatest problems and it's
my pleasure now to welcome you to that
family
to be part of that that very very rich
tradition
let me also add my congratulations and
my admiration to the
to naveens in terms of the amount of
energy and time that you put in
it is not easy to take on a program of
this caliber
several years ago when when
the partnership with simply learn and
caltech began
we both discussed the fact that
that
we needed the postgraduate programs to
be very very meaningful and that they
would be very very challenging and
rigorous would require
many hundreds of hours of effort
very significant
things but we wanted the programs to be
something that
that left you with a set of job ready
skills
with a certificate that would be
impressive to potential employers
with the ability to really kind of solve
some of the the big challenges that we
have in industry and i'm very very
pleased that
between the efforts of simply learning
caltech we've put together that type of
a program so
um you are to be commended for the
energy
that you put in for the time
that you did
and i would also like to express my
thanks to your your friends and family
um when
a learner is involved in a program of
this magnitude it impacts their entire
household um and so i'm sure there have
been
uh people that have covered other
responsibilities that you have um have
allowed you quiet time to work on
classes or attend zoom or
other things and so that's that's uh
that's really significant so please
remember
learners to thank the people in your
family for the sacrifices that they've
made to help you get to this point as
well
um
at this point um
we're really hopeful that you can take
the knowledge that you gained in these
programs and go out and use them out in
the workplace
we want to continue to stay in touch
with you
and so
you all are now members in the caltech
circle which is the alumni cup
group for our professional classes so
you'll be getting other additional
information in the near future about the
uh circle
and
details
we'll be keeping you involved in
activities ongoing at cal tech and other
places that we think could enrich your
career and we hope you'll be interested
in
but most of all let me just really wish
you the best of luck
in your career
go forward make us proud
and take advantage of the learning that
you you've accomplished so
congratulations to all of you anon let
me turn it back over to you
thanks rick and i think we have mike
here now too so i would rather mike
speak before me mike would you like to
take a stage and then i'll take it over
from there
absolutely um
welcome everybody uh we're really happy
that you can be a part of this
we're honored to be a part of this i
don't want to say on on behalf of the
california institute of technology
and the center that that rick and i lead
we really want to commend you for your
personal commitment
i think naveen
and and and rick and i have said it well
but it's really your passion
for learning and the support from your
families and employers that help you get
through this program you know embarking
on a
nearly year-long
program to learn new skills and
unfamiliar areas
is both challenging but it's also
incredibly rewarding and and we're glad
that uh you're a part of that with us
um you know over the last couple of
years
it's been amazing to watch this program
grow
um you're in an amazing community you
know with the simply learn programs
we've had
representation from over 60 countries
many of you
come are coming from the us and india
but also from africa and from europe and
and places far away that normally we
would never
um because we usually have local
programs in california maybe people
can't experience what it's like to do
something with caltech and so
simplylearn has helped us
create that reach and given you a
platform that you could learn from
we want to welcome you to the community
later on this afternoon you'll receive
messages about caltech circle
and joining that through linkedin if you
have any questions please let us know
you will get regular content
um keep up to date on what's happening
with caltech
invite you to a few different functions
and events and really we'd like you to
engage with
with the other learners who have also
completed certificates not just from
simply learn but also out of our
engineering programs or leadership
programs from caltech
we wish you the best of luck in software
development and your engineering careers
these are incredible journeys um and
with kind of very industrious
uh learners like yourselves
um and being good problem solvers along
the way
um i feel good about the future um and
we're glad that uh
you're here with us
thank you
thank you mike thank you rick really
appreciate that so let me add just a few
points first of all let me echo all the
sentiments right
we have 365 graduates of which more than
200 are here today
very very excited to see this so first
of all you know just having that many
folks around here who have actually
finished the cloud devops our full stack
program is just something that's amazing
right let me tell you some more stats
right the folks that have actually taken
those these programs come from 100 plus
countries
and 70 plus of those folks have actually
either a bachelor's or master's degree
and some even have a phd right so the
first thing you got to realize is the
folks that are around you
these are people who are going to be
forced to reckon
and all these folks who have got a
caltech certificate they've got the
knowledge you know to take them further
and they're going to be the moors and
shakers of tomorrow
so one thing i'd like to strongly
recommend is stay in touch with the
folks that actually took these courses
with you stay in touch with these
cohorts make sure that you're connected
with these folks and make sure you don't
lose that connection with celtic i know
mike and rick and we and ravine and i
will make sure that you get the
information on the captive circle that
you get included in those but realize
you're part of an elite set of students
now that have achieved something pretty
amazing and it doesn't end here right
that community has to continue you have
to stay in touch with the folks around
you and keep that community strong so i
wish you all the very best i know
everybody's going to have amazing
careers they're going to use this
knowledge to the best of your abilities
in your jobs and you know
congratulations you made it you made it
to this point which is an amazing
achievement and we wish you all the very
best with that said naveen let's uh
let's go through the ceremony let's uh
you know let's announce all the winners
and sure reports today which is the
exciting part of this uh program i think
back to you sure sure thank you so much
thank you rick thank you mike thank you
thank you for all the kind words and i'm
pretty sure um
everyone will resonate with the thoughts
that you had
uh today is indeed a celebration a
celebration to acknowledge everyone's
hard work and dedication and intent and
grit you guys have put in completing the
post-graduation program with caltech ctm
and simply learn before we get to the
graduates um will it not be great to
hear about what your peers think about
the program so few of your peers have
volunteered to share their experience
with us and uh we would call upon a few
learners who
want you to speak in the conversation so
i would i would like to call upon john
kerris
john if you are
there if you could
speak few words can you hear me yes we
can yeah john perfect thank you
greetings everyone today i'd like to
share a bit of my journey over the last
year and a half with the cdtme
postgraduate program
at the beginning i had a small
understanding of how cloud systems
really operated and functioned but this
program let me standard a study under
some wonderful instructors who guided me
step by step through each certification
topic and platform
from basic cloud information and
vocabulary to working directly on devops
and sysop solutions i got to delve into
what it meant to work on and with
cloud-based solutions
as a software engineer this experience
was invaluable as it helped give me
not only greater insight into what i
could use cloud computing for in my
day-to-day personal and work life but
also how i could use this new knowledge
to shape my future
since the completion of the program i've
been spending more time directly with
the aws and
azure platforms building some new
projects while also trying to slowly
search and transition to a cloud
computing job engineering position in
the future
i would like to uh quickly say a quick
thanks to my family uh because without
their unwavering support the decision to
go into this program would have been a
lot more difficult
and thank you all for the support and
care you've shown me and thank you to
simply learning caltech for the
incredible experience
thank you thank you so much john thank
you that was really kind of new and we
hope the very best for you in the future
all right next
next we have uh anut singh from pgb
cloud computing anuj if you're there
thank you so much naveen um
i'm really thankful for organizing this
event and uh really delighted to be part
of such a journey
and just to share reflect on my
experience i think so it's almost a year
back where i made a decision to join
the this prestigious program if i may
say and
i think so this has helped me to
build up a foundation and a building
block block for my learning journey and
especially in the cloud space where i
had no experience no knowledge in that
and i'm happy that uh
joining this course i got to know a lot
of things which were very new to me and
and
if i see on my reflect on my career i
think so it'll help me to transition
into the cloud space
and most importantly i would really want
to take an opportunity to thank every
one of you and i mean you being there
abhishek madhurima and
things from the back end aryan and
are my account managers and all so they
were quite helpful and everyone really
helped me to uh
stitch up the learning journey in such a
fabulous way uh that i'm super delighted
and thankful and if not have been
possible and some names which come top
of my mind would be
uh our instructor shruti and our master
class faculties uh
dr uh john so uh i'm really thankful to
each one of you and voting naveen thanks
a lot
thank you thank you so much thank you
for sharing your experience with us uh
we wish you all luck and we wish you all
the very best for your future
uh next we have paul gallerio
paul if you're there
hey paul i can see you in the panelist
can you hear us
yes
yes we can hear you well okay our cohort
in devops started last may may 2021
basically i don't have background in
devops
and thanks to simply learn i was able to
learn the most in demand
skill sets and tools
that are used by
devops professionals in the industry
the instructors were very very very
patient and they answered our questions
thoroughly
and at the end of every session they
gave us challenges
that made us
more
skilled in terms of
our devops tools
and
because of that this month i was
informed by my manager that he will
recommend me for an award because i was
able to automate yes because i was able
to automate their servers using ansible
and jenkins
that saved that made them save as much
as
to 100 000
in savings because we automated the
stop start of the servers and because of
that i would like to thank you
simply learn and caltech for unlocking
these opportunities for us
this course truly changed our lives
thank you it's an amazing story paul
amazing story we are really really
glad that you could put all your
learnings into your work and
you you kind of get the right
appreciation for it we are really glad
that we helped you in your journey to
success thank you so much paul for
sharing your story thank you so much
thank you
next we have
millen with poker
who's from uh rpg devops
hello milan can you hear us well
i can hear you
i'm audible yes milan i can see you as
well
oh
hello everyone my name is milan with
bowker and i've been working as a devops
infrastructure engineer for a cyber
security firm called fortinet
based out of sunnyvale california for
the past two years
and prior to joining fortinet i worked
for dell emc for almost 14 years
and i was delivering mostly
infrastructure solutions to dell
customers and my expertise primarily had
been on server storage you know
networking and virtualization
so i had no prior experience in devops
before joining fortinet
and i was kind of researching online for
some help
and i was kind of lost and i didn't know
where to start and then i came across
this uh
you know postgraduate program in devops
from caltech ctme in collaboration with
simply learn and i looked at the
syllabus and it was very much structured
and you know the combination of
the online sessions
uh the
labs you know and the capstone project
that made it very appealing and when i
submitted the application and
right from the beginning you know my
experience was very good
my application was reviewed quickly and
just like that i was on board with this
course
and i was very much excited to start
this journey and uh committed myself to
weekend saturday and sunday for four
hours in the morning
i actually started twice in my head i
thought that could have been bad
where is picking up from
it's actually i'm just happy they didn't
turn the camera on no but the next
person either i'll stick that video on
okay there's a time delay too i'm sure
for some reason
attendees to please mute themselves
sure thanks thanks thank you that's much
better
yeah yeah that's better yes
yeah so um um you know i was very much
excited to start this journey and
committed myself to every weekend
saturday and sunday 6 30 to
you know 10 30 based out of california
for almost nine months and there was a
lot of anxiety
at the start of the course
but soon i found myself engaged in some
serious learning you know and time was
really flying by
four sessions every weekend were flying
and i was enjoying myself thoroughly
the faculties were all from industry
background
and
that made those sessions very
interesting and they were also sharing
their experiences also i had almost like
25 talented individuals in my cohort and
they also asked interesting questions
and some of them also shared their
challenges and experiences so that also
made learning very much fun and all the
instructors
did a fabulous job and made sure that
concepts were reinforced by going
through the quizzes and giving us
sufficient time with the labs and giving
pointers to
you know for all the projects um as a
result of completing this course i've
started to get more assignments at work
and i'm also looking forward to build a
kubernetes environment
so i would like to thank all my faculty
members and
i would like to begin with abhijit who
set the bar high delivering the first
devops overview course abrash with some
excellent white boarding sessions
explaining the git version control
system in detail
rageindra covering the jenkins building
blocks wyatt free lot i can say is a
terraform master
and
you know
also sebastian kolomar
who took our kubernetes
kubernetes
and um
you know thank you for diving sharma for
giving pointers to the capstone project
um and
it was a lot of fun working on a
capstone infrastructure project building
a
building a kubernetes environment in the
aws cloud
and i would also enjoyed the
the master class by matthew dartes it
was nice to know some industry trends
and last but not least you know simply
learn support nehal for timely support
um
and i would also like to thank my wife
for all my support making sure that the
coffee machine was was always on all
over the weekends
and i think learning should never stop
once again thank you caltech and simply
learn
thank you thank you so much milan we
wish you all success and thank you for
taking out your time and giving us a
very detailed
uh feedback so it's really nice to hear
from you and uh i
i wish you wish you all the
best for
everything that has in the future for
you thank you so much milan thank you
davin i appreciate everyone's questions
thank you
all right next we have uh vishwanath
kota
who's from the pg cloud computing world
should not if you're there
hello
yes
i see you there yeah hi
first of all i congratulate everyone for
this
admin success and i would like to
welcome everyone
so uh it's been honored to be a part of
this pg program
conducted by simply run with
collaboration with caltech university
so basically uh
right after my
graduation i was looking i was so
obsessed with cloud and i was i wanted
to know more about it and uh actually uh
i felt like i wanted to do on cloud
computing so then i started my research
and i came to conclusion that the
simplest might be a best platform to
to be so i've choose that and my best
experience was the first day when my
cohort started
so it's like our mentor asked us to ex
introduce ourselves
so
it's like when they started introducing
themselves and later on i realized that
i was i was the only person in my cohort
like having around two years of
experience in id industry and the rest
of all that like 15 years seven years 10
years like managers tls and i was
literally i was frightened whether i
could made it or not because see like
the my cohort and my peers were so
highly experienced that i've just have a
two years of experience like i was like
two years with the two years as a
software engineers so i was little bit
frightened but later on when i started
that uh i mentor geethika who have
guided us uh and her delivery style was
loot and she made me comfort uh and she
explained in a keen way so that i could
get into it
and uh from starting from zero i had
learned many things about cloud how it
works azure and it helped me boost my
confidence as well like with two years
of experience having a pg degree is uh
it's a great thing for me it's like it's
mean a lot to me and i will uh mainly
share the simple and like they have
provided me labs which i got most of it
how implementation through the classes
and everything so the projects and
everything was well organized and well
given to us so i would this degree means
a lot to me and i would like to thank
each and everyone who helped me in this
journey and made it possible thanks to
simpler and cal tech university and i
hope to collaborate with them in future
as well thanks thanks everyone
thank you thank you so much
it was it was really nice to hear your
story and all the very best for the
future and uh we wish you
the young graduate we wish you all the
very best for your future yeah thanks
yeah
next we have uh ramachandra rachella
machandra if
yes i can hear you then yes hi thank you
naveen for giving this opportunity i
first of all thank
caltech management and simply learn
for hosting this
event today and also
hosting the proceedings all through the
nine months to 10 months and staging
that platform for me and many others
i
thank
dr hefner
chief guest
mike
and anand here
i would like to confess that uh this
training has strengthened my knowledge
in cloud computing
this has helped me this course has
helped me
attend
many interviews first of all made me
eligible for many jobs and i have
actually cleared many interviews with
great confidence
i answered many questions uh thanks to
that lab and the projects which actually
pulled a lot of our knowledge into that
small projects and
made us familiar with the platform and
the integrities of the cloud platform
and
especially i would like to mention the
name of the instructor
shruti sinha
she not only laid the strong foundation
in my strong foundation in cloud but
also
helped me clarify my doubts and myths in
the
topics
so i'm very thankful to her as well
and i would
thank all my cohort members and the
participants here
and i encourage
doing such uh courses further together
like the way we did it already
thank you uh everyone i wish you all
thank you so much
thank you for sharing your story and we
wish you all the best and uh you just
we should
reach more heights in your career and uh
all the very best ramachandra thank you
next next we have uh surish krishna
suresh if you're available
yes i can see insurance
okay yeah uh good morning good evening
good afternoon
um i'm really happy to attend this
session i'd like to thank caltech
management staff and also simply learn
i pursued this program in um cloud
computing
even though like i had some exposure but
i wanted to take the step extra step of
uh
learning in depth and definitely i was
able to achieve that goal and to add a
little perspective how this helped um
overall in my career
so my i work for as a back-end engineer
for a company based out in san francisco
and we are in already in aws but the
management we're
planning to uh you know adopt other
cloud platform providers in addition to
aws
and this course definitely helped me to
take the perspective and move forward
and in fact like we are in
multiple cloud provider i mean some of
the solutions based on the cost
perspective so this definitely helped to
meet that meet that corporate goals and
i'm happy that i was able to be part of
it like so um and a few key colors i
want to make uh simply learn uh teaching
staff and support staffs were incredible
and one key callout i want to make it
here is um um
the instructor praveen i mean i'm i'm
and the reason why i'm calling out he
went an extra mile uh during this uh
cohort session
like he despite uh himself and his
family got affected with covet he still
had a dedication to take the class and
took an extra mile that was really
really incredible and i'd like to thank
and not only him like the entire staff
like you know for supporting
and definitely i feel that learning even
though we finish and we take this kind
of course learning is a constant we keep
to keep approaching every time as we
progress that's my uh inclination and i
would like to and i'd like to make a
point like i will continue this journey
and before taking it all like i would
like to congratulate all and congrats
all the graduates and thank you all from
now
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much it was really nice to hear it from
you and we will definitely pass on your
uh feedback to praveen as well thank you
so much and we wish you all the very
best for the future
all right so uh uh
based on the time we have one last one
that we can pick up uh
jesse
uh lens on
uh jesse if you're there
yes i can see you jesse hey jesse i can
see you but
yes i can yeah i would be interested
good evening uh good morning everyone
um
i'm excited to share my journey
uh i took the leap last september um to
join the
postgraduate program in cloud computing
and it was actually a daunting
experience but at the same time it's
both challenging and sweet and i think
everyone can relate because
uh you had to juggle between work take
care of your family
i had to
spend
sleepless nights
just to actually attend the
classes during weekends and of course
prepare for the certification exams at
the same time
but it was actually um
fruitful and it was all worth it
um it also helped me grow
my confidence right instead of just
leveling up in terms of skills it
actually helped me grow as an individual
to
be able to trust myself in what i can do
and in terms of
my journey and career
and how it helped me grow
um i had a software engineering chapter
in our organization
and we have a cloud first policy but we
wanted to go multi-cloud
and this actually helped us migrate
several workloads um
into the different types of cloud
whether aws or google
and
it actually catapulted us
in terms of accelerating our digital
transformation and cloud native group
so
i thank you um
my my family my wife actually for
uh being patient uh
um
for all the
um
the sleepless nights and
i think also uh the simply learning
instructors
for being there um whenever we ask
questions and the support team for
giving timely relevant answers
and i appreciate all the instructors
and the professors in the master class
sessions uh this is actually a game
changer
and i believe that
this program that you guys
have
can help us
change the world make it better one
learning journey at the time
thank you thank you so much jesse yeah
we really like to congratulate you and
uh all the best for the future we wish
you all the best we wish you and your
wife all the very best for the future
that works for you thank you so much
jesse
it's so nice to hear such success
stories i'm pretty sure many of you
would also have many more to tell but
due to time we will move on
so now it's time to celebrate success uh
it's time to honor each and every one
who has completed the rpg program with
us we would like to give you a very
quick snippet of the number of uh
qualified learners here we have around
80 learners from six cohort qualified
for pg devops we have around 253
learners from 16 cohorts qualified for
cloud computing and we have 18 learners
from three cohorts who have qualified
for uh from full stacked web development
course
all right now moving on to the fell
station of all the graduates um i would
first like to apologize before we
proceed because i may not pronounce all
the names right so please bear with me
we will start with devops
all right
we have greg
aishwarya
i'm getting this chats one second
i missed uh one second
thank you
congratulation all the graduates we have
chirag milan
we have eric
zakaria armin
many congratulation graduates
we have amishka
francisco kumar
earnest
many congratulations
we have matthew we have kai
gautam lewis
andrew mohammed show him
chris
and us anderson
alexandru archie mohammad abed
prashanth sandeep kumar
many congratulations everyone
we have dawood
muhammad umar udita
ravikumar
francis and mini jayanti many
congratulations to all the devops
program graduates many many
congratulations
next we move on to cloud computing
we have arnab
vikas
williams
rohit ramachandra
lakshmi
runwish
david
andrei
mohammed
uh many congratulations uh graduates we
have sheetul
anil
pratap
shrikant
aishwarya
satyaki
american relations graduates
vishwanath
many congratulations all the graduates
we have manish
guyan
varun
sam
anuj
subhajit
rajesh
suresh raunee
samia
alan
very congratulations
we have smithy
shahid
krishna
ashish
chandan
many congratulations all the graduates
we have sheikh
we have albude we have ubis allen
sajeet
silva ganesh
muhammad safan
john
briber
ravindra paul
putra narayan
because
congratulations everyone
we have surjit we have aashman we have
mohammed salad
we have darshan
benjamin
rajesh suresh
satya
nick maslina
when you congratulation all graduates
we have aneesh
karthik and isha
many congratulations
we have
domenico padmanaban mega
cyril ganesh
shipra kamula ganesh
chandrahar
riju
manixa
zhiyan karlo
mario
daniel
yogesh
ayman
davin
nithan
michael
arlando
liju
ryan
adarsh ankur and falguni many
congratulations to all the graduates i'm
pretty sure you'll be happy to see your
name as well as your cohort people's uh
name as well
next we have david
nathesh
oliver
rajiv saleem
jb daniel deepa silva ganesh chaitan
oscar
gerard nilava
emily
rajiv kunal
on
and frank
congratulations all cloud computing
graduates
we have predita
we have bharat we have prasad
we have taretta
abhishek
michael
balaji
ash
vernes
rohit
andreas constantinius
michael
and francis
very congratulations all the winners all
the graduates
we have
brahman
many congratulations to everyone
then we have shruti vyan
kathleen
nabadi
karthik
ahmed
maryam guru prasanna swati
very congratulations all the cloud
computing graduates
it's so nice to see so many graduates
come out of
other courses it's it's really a
fun thing to see next we move on to uh
full stack
we have
we have noel
sonali
we have mohammed vahdur
lily
many congratulations full stack web
development graduates and many
congratulations to everyone who have
graduated today
it's not easy i'm pretty sure it was not
easy and uh
i'm pretty sure i'll just give you all a
moment to celebrate your success i'll
just watch the chat
so that
you can exchange congratulations
okay
all right
moving on
we know that all of you are achievers
here since the journey is
something which is not very easy
right but uh but there are few learners
who went a step beyond and displayed
their competitive spirit
uh we have two sets of award planned for
the evening and the first category of
award is the scholar award uh here we
fell state the top two performers in
each category in terms of completing the
allied classes the projects that
assessments with the highest cumulative
scores
first i would like to call on the
callers for postgraduate program in
devops
we have zakaria who has scored 87.25
and we have ernest who has scored 84.6
if zakaria and ernest if you're there
everyone would like to hear from you
zakaria are you there um honest
all right i see zakaria
zach
is that that's the career is that you
yeah yeah yeah can you hear me yes i can
hear you well
yeah um so firstly i just want to thank
um caltrak and simply lent him for this
particular program
um so the reason being is
it covered most tools that have been
used in the industry and it was
structured in a very simple manner um in
a way that um like even the beginners
would actually understand
um
i could see like melastor will be um
thank you for paving way um just for us
and those two
just those who are just about to take up
the course so thank you for whatever you
have done and thank you for the team so
thank you thank you thank you so much
zakaria thank you so much
congratulations on being us being one of
the scholars
ah thank you thank you thank you so much
nevin
and uh ernest
oh i see honest yes
on a second you should unmute yourself
how do i unmute yes there you go
you can speak now honest
all right
a good day to everyone present here
so
uh it seems it's my privilege to be here
today thank you so much for having me
here so
when i first rested this class i was
very very nervous i thought maybe
i i wouldn't i wasn't going to make it
because of work and other stuff
so yeah my today
so i want to say
we had really great instructors and very
knowledgeable in the way they delivered
their courses
so this training was well structured and
organized and i want to encourage anyone
out there that wants to like start
their
career at 90
that simply learn is the best place to
start
and um it's not only for starters but
also for those who wants to like improve
on
their present skills yeah
so
really it was a tough journey but
happy we were able to do it
so i also want to take this opportunity
to thank my family and friends for their
support and especially my
my kid brother desmond coco who was
there all the time for me and
thank you thanks to simplylane and
caltech
what a great opportunity thank you
thank you so much ernest thank you for
sharing your thoughts and a special hi
to cuckoo
all right moving on so uh from cloud
computing we have uh isha suryawanshi
who has stored an astonishing 90 percent
and we have alan costa who's just behind
isha scoring 88.4
so if uh isha and alan if you are here
we can bump you up
and share your thoughts
hey i can see you there
yeah thank you naveen
um and hello everyone
i am delighted and honored to be part of
the com convocation ceremony today and
icing on the cake being awarded the
scholar
okay congratulations on that
yeah thank you so much um i would start
by thanking simply learn and caltech for
providing professionals like me
an opportunity to enhance our knowledge
um i have been quite fortunate to learn
from some of the best instructors
um they have been very patient answering
my questions i really i really you know
thank to them
and um of course my very knowledgeable
batch mates
um they have also been patient answering
some of my questions so really kudos to
their patients as well um
well i'm grateful
for my instructors and batman's for
their guidance and help you know
throughout this course
um so i would like to conclude by saying
um this was my first time taking an
online course and
because of this wonderful experience i'm
planning to learn more with sim with the
help of simply learn
thank you so much and definitely cheers
to
all of my fellow achievers
and all the best for your future
endeavors thank you naveen
thank you so much it was very kind of
you
thank you so much and all the very best
for the future
it's astonishing to see you in school 90
honestly
yeah for me too
i'm astonished as well
yeah good job there
all right we move on
uh next is the full stack web
development course this is one of the
toughest tracks that we have and we have
uh kaya 3 nagre who has scored 65
percent and we have imran m raji
west coat 65 as well so if gayatri and
imran if you're here we can bump you up
share your thoughts
okay looks like
there and uh i'm very glad to hear from
all the scholars and many
congratulations uh to everyone who has
been awarded today so uh
we move on to the second set of awards
which uh recognizes who was uh able to
complete the program end to end in the
shortest duration we call them the speed
runners
and for pg devops we have armen shamas
who has
completed the course in 148 days and we
have chirag lady who has completed the
course in 171 days many congratulations
both of you and if i mean or chirag if
you are available we can pop you up and
you can
yes i can see armin
okay i mean i can see you you can admit
yourself and you can
everyone can you hear me yes we can hear
your admin
i wanna
hi everyone i wanna thank you for having
me here
um it's been a great pleasure to be part
of this valuable program uh i think
simple learning is the best place to
learn
i learned so much things in these
courses like advanced about currencies
and jenkins and dockers
they're very great hands-on labs
all the courses were organized very well
i recommend this to everyone that wants
a big boost in their career
also i wanna uh thanks uh
simpler name on the support uh i wish
the best of luck to everyone
thank you so much armin thank you so
much it would be great if you could it
was a trick and tricks uh how you could
complete this course faster maybe next
time
yeah so thank you sure thank you so much
admin
moving on
for cloud computing we have uh sadashiv
nayak
who has done the course in one or two
days and we have andres iwan
who has also done the course in one or
two days this is astonishing to see them
complete the course and record amount of
time
and if sadashiv or andres if you are
available
we can we can
we would like to hear from you
all right
okay
uh many congratulations by the way
survivor andres
uh next we move on to uh pg fsd
we have farsa ahmadi nasa iran who has
completed one of the toughest scores in
like 172 days and again we have imran m
rajiv who has done the course in like
two not five days so many
congratulations both of you this is uh
really uh an achievable an achievement
that speaks volumes about your
dedication and uh sheer determination to
complete the course uh if uh parsa or
imran if you are available
we can we can
the crowd would like to hear you speak
it's like
a lot
anyway moving on um we know everyone is
a winner here so uh and uh many many
congratulations to uh the scholars and
uh speedrunners for standing out and uh
thank you everyone for and
congratulations everyone uh apart from
the graduates uh who have uh shared
their experience with us uh we would
also like to thank all of you uh who
have actively reviewing us in different
social media platforms time and now uh
we are super happy and uh excited to
have all your feedback put in different
social media and we also have received
feedback which has made us work harder
and fix a lot of things and move forward
and giving you the best of the learning
experience thank you so much for that
next uh i would like to introduce the
team uh which is behind the success so
uh i would like to introduce the team
behind the scenes that works
relentlessly to make sure that you have
the best of the experience right the
idea behind this is to put a face to the
names that you've heard and attracted in
the last past one year so first i would
like to introduce our faculty team
uh i would like to take this opportunity
to thank our faculty for constantly
supporting us throughout the program
they have been the major pillars of your
experience and we would like to call out
each faculty and thank them on your
behalf
we have bill bake we have naresh chigar
patak ashitosh bakri
thank you so much instructors trainers
uh
for all the
uh good work that you have done and we
have been we have successfully graduated
350 learners and everyone couldn't kind
of see how valuable your inputs and your
sessions were so if any trainer is
available we would like to hear from one
of the trainers
anyone uh penetrator available
so that we can have them speak
i i guess i saw bill bake if build is
available we can kind of share a few
words
all right
okay so moving on uh then we would like
to thank our master class instructors uh
who are part of uh uh who are part of
the caltech family fellow stating us uh
with different topics every month right
we have dr john
uh we have equine we have matthew
tatters we have patrick alexander chris
boyston and dave dorado thank you so
much masterclass instructors that your
sessions are extremely valuable and we
couldn't thank you more
moving on to the core team at simply
learn the learner success team
here's the team who's responsible for
the sessions and the tickets that you
post
many would have interacted with them
directly or indirectly we have aryan
arun radhakrishnan
muhammad maaz
imran
we have the program managers
that is me
then we have madurama we have abhishek
trapati and we have lucy
then we have
the product team the team uh that our
brains behind curating uh sorry we have
the definite team uh the faculty and
alignment team which is responsible for
hand picking and getting us the best of
traders we have uh keshava from the team
and we have ayman russian
and we have the product team the team
that is behind
behind the scenes curating the program
and structuring it they have been the
bridge between simplyland and celtic and
the drivers of the program uh we have
sagar raj in padilla we have archana we
have mayan we have sahajas from the team
then we have the content team
uh the team that is responsible for all
the content and curriculum that we see
in terms of live virtual classes as well
as self-learning videos the team
consists of raja tagarwal ravital siyani
anjana singh and shmita surendra
let let's take a moment and applaud and
thank
for thank them for all their efforts
thank you so much team this wouldn't
have been possible without you pulling
it off thank you so much
so uh this brings us to the end of our
second edition of uh online convocation
for postgraduate program with caltech
ctme in association with simplylearn
we wish each and every graduate all the
best for their future and we believe
being aspirational is the first part of
being successful and you come here with
an aspiration and a dream and we are
pretty sure uh many of you will excel in
different streams of aquarium
uh we want you to leave with one thought
today uh you are now the ambassadors of
caltech ctme simply long teaching
programs so uh people will follow you
your footsteps and uh you will be the
guiding light to success so we would
request you to be active in your
communities and uh post some interesting
topics there so that the future learners
can also keep uh and also keep us posted
about your success stories so that we as
well as the future learners can look
into it and uh enlighten themselves so
once again it's a heartfelt gratitude
for us uh from us for you choosing
simply learn to be your partner to skill
up thank you again uh once again from uh
on behalf of caltech and simply learn
and thank you everyone for making time
for this even
good night everyone good day and uh good
luck everybody
we'll be here for another uh five
minutes uh if you have any questions or
anything we can we can check that out
before we end the session
each other's side um i will
check um so like in the in the program
we were
told that there will be some ceos also
being awarded
yeah
yeah so uh so do we have to wait for
those or how does it you'll get you will
get all those details
so you will get the catholic membership
everything will be given to you
okay yeah thank you
so much
thank you everyone for being there and
being patient uh and attending the
convocation and i'm pretty sure uh you
guys will excel in whatever streams you
work on so uh thank you everyone and
good night take care
you